over the course of two years a  mysterious object took form in the  middle of the new mexican desert  a strange structure designed to subvert  the norms of the space launch industry a  space catapult  in our new exclusive behind the scenes  documentary i talk to the people behind  this new innovative company  and again it's like faster than the  blink of an eye so you'll see a little  bit of settling as it as after it closes  um but it's you know  basically 95 closed within you know 30  milliseconds oh wow okay closing airlock  and five four  three  two  one  it's pretty fast yeah that's not what i  was expecting  subscribe to watch our 40 minute long  behind the scenes documentary with spin  launch